the elephant in the room look at the
border okay why is it if the federal
government is so concerned with covet
spreading in the United States of
America why is it that Americans have to
go on lockdown why is it that Americans
have to receive these mandatory job
mandates but there are millions of
people since Biden has taken office that
have flooded over the United States
Southern border not a single vaccine
mandate has been issued to these people
that are not even Americans you want to
know what's pissing Americans off right
now whether left or right is that there
are people that are coming from
different countries freely over the
southern border without any job mandates
but Americans are losing their lives
First Responders medical examiners
people that are professionals people
that have dedicated their lives that are
experts that are now being put out on
the streets they're Americans and that
is what's bothering the governor of the
document just came out I gotta say this
I don't want it the document just came
out the Minnesota Governor said in
Flight covered numbers okay the shutdown
going this is what really really annoys
me about all this Drew just made a
massive political point I was Megan and
everybody keeps going back into the
argument about we should we should all
sit under the mandates but discuss the
science when no one here knows what the
[ __ ] they're talking about what I do
know is that a million plus people did
cross the border with not a single
mandate but they are firing nurses and
then people argue natural immunity and
they argue big and I'm like I don't care
about any of that you are not going to
mandate a public policy on the people
and then ban people numbers
for sure it's a power move yeah but but
why is I 100 percent said I want to lock
down for power he admits it's all a
fraud this is Smoking Gun no listen this
is why I am so hell-bent on talk to your
doctor we're not going to discuss yeah
why is the Minnesota governor no no no
dude you are driving us back into an
argument that takes us away from the
fact that they are mandating a medical
procedure I don't care if it's an x-ray
I don't care if it's a physical I don't
care if they want to feel my toes we
shouldn't be sitting here going like
well this sign just said this and they
were talking about numbers no a million
people crossed the southern border with
no mandate firefighters police nurses
fired from their jobs and all anyone
keeps doing is keep saying let's have a
conversation about efficacy is
irrelevant you talk to your doctor you
figure out what makes sense for you and
I'll tell you this your mandates are
meaningless yeah it's two different
arguments I agree with you nobody
disagree I'm saying the governor I don't
know most people don't know about the
people Joe's right no most people don't
know let's talk more about that the
Minnesota Governor admits the lockdown
was for political control he got caught
in emails sorry yeah well how many
people know that people are literally
not just being allowed across the border
but actually like allowed to enter into
the country yeah we've got to do that to
fly on airplanes
legally if you're coming legally you
have to have the covet vaccine now and
again we understand this was never about
your health this was always about your
subjugation you look at what happened
where they mandate this medical
procedure where they have the most
strictest vaccine passports in England
in Israel real in Singapore you see the
highest rises in cases Gibraltar one of
the most vaccinated places in the world
just canceled Christmas because they had
a surge in coveted cases Vermont has the
highest cases in America and it's the
highest facts exactly that's all Bernie
Sanders fault that's what I heard it is
they want they want to control we've
talked about this Alex right they want a
controllable class they want a two-tier
system they want the Elites at the top
and they want the people at the bottom
that they could control that are not
going to say anything that are not going
to protest that are not going to fuss
about it because they want people come
millions of people they want people in
this country that are illiterate to the
United States Constitution so that they
don't protest or fuss about it it's not
left or right democrat or republican
they just want people that they could
control and what's happening at the
southern border is literally proving
that right now as I speak it's not
stopping it's not stopping anything this
is why I tell people it doesn't matter
it's not left or right it's not
Republican or Democratic okay
yeah this is why you can't have this
many people on a [ __ ] podcast
everybody just starts yelling okay let
me let me correct this Sean Hannity just
everybody's saving lives the Americans
don't care about the Constitution this
is just Boomer bullcrap that people
spout on Fox News so you think the
United States Constitution is Boomer
bullcrap is that what you're saying yeah
interesting 100 Russia if you looked at
what happened Russia if you look at what
happened with the lockdowns they did not
have to use a lot of force the
overwhelming majority of people were
more than happy to have their freedoms
taken away for the illusion of safety
the average man does not want to be free
he merely wants to be safe and the
conservation is Keith Urban
No One's Gonna Know No One's Gonna know
that reference and the Constitution has
been a dead letter
from the George Washington
administration they were locking people
up for criticizing the government in the
1790s it's a complete joke we said
wars.com
their Mine Fields before us where they
they they pull you in their direction
I've talked about how the conservatives
that there's no real opposition to the
left other than like the Democrats will
come out and say we want to ban assault
rifles and the Republicans will say no
but where is the Republican leadership
this is actually something you told me
where is the Republican leadership come
out and say we want to abolish gun laws
everything is always the establishment
left is pulling us in this direction and
the right is just saying slow down say
the quote conservatism is progressivism
driving the speed limit oh there you go
so this is why you know we had a
conversation a while ago about science
and Pfizer and all these pills and stuff
and I was like yo are we actually just
arguing the degree to which we are going
to live under the mandates I agree but
what about the Exodus of the people from
mainstream media Joe everything's
collapsing your show is the epicenter of
everybody leaving the establishment and
going to Independent how does how does
dinosaur media finally die because if
Joe Rogan's the meteorite to hit the
planet kill dinosaurs it doesn't have to
die am radio's still around too
well let's just say let it just like let
let's keep it alive
let's keep it alive barely Alex do you
know who you want you don't want your
enemy to die you want you to keep your
foot on its chest looks like a little
zombie you know how it's gonna you know
how it's gonna you know it's how it's
gonna lose it it's gonna lose its
efficacy when CNN and fox and MSNBC are
looked at exactly like a look at
Marlboro or Lucky Strikes when the
average American regards a corporate
journalist exactly as they regard
tobacco Executives you know they're
selling your product you know that
product's deadly let them sell it yeah
but people want to buy it but that's all
it is Lucky Strikes gives you a nice
Head Rush well so does watching these
shows because you hate the Liberals you
hate the conservatives Lucky Strikes you
get to go to flavor country for a little
bit now how much stuff like filterless
camera we should we should ask ourselves
how much support does the corporate
media have and how much of it is an
illusion they don't anymore yes
the average CNN show has a hundred
thousand viewers if they're lucky right
yeah but we know many of them are
actually like into it right how many
were just flip into the channels Joe
Rogan farts he gets five million views
but if you if you like if you're
flipping through the channels are you
really into it is it something you're
looking forward to I mean how many
people are actually looking forward to
no you're like look at Brian stelter
he's a sack of Filth he's a fake fraud
the [ __ ] are you saying like they seek
the personalities all right I love him I
actually have a sexual desire I'm still
on this I think the corporate media is
now alphabet Google Facebook will meta
uh right and how do we face this in the
next 20 years if they're smart what they
would do is go back to straight news
straight objective just have all the
apps a plane crash have all the ads you
want but have objective
completely unbiased news if they did
that I think it would turn it around if
we knew that everyone that was reading
all the news if we get to a point
through all these independent social
media applications and the distribution
of information when we know what they're
saying is verified we know it's true so
they have to tell the truth if they just
told the truth and give you a synopsis
of what's happening in the world they
would actually make more money
it's not possible because at the very
least they're gonna have a bias in terms
of what they cover what they don't maybe
or maybe they just get together with a
panel that decides like what is the most
important in terms of National Security
the economy well all the different
things about climate what are what are
the issues that are really that we know
are real that we can cover in an
unbiased way if someone came along and
did that I guarantee you you would get
enough of people from both sides once
it's been clearly established that it's
actually unbiased news I think they
would be massively commercially
successful but look at look at the irony
and they do it by saying it's like
here's this person let's take a look at
breaking points with Crystal and cigar
sauger soccer perfect example but no
they're getting smeared as alt right and
far right now bunch of [ __ ]
but Their audience that's that's true
there's a there's an issue with this
this idea of the left populists and the
right popular less can calm challenge
the elites Crystal and cigar were
saggers
[ __ ] say his name more time soccer
soccer
Braveheart so uh we did a segment on the
show uh Young Turks said that you know
Joe Rogan's basically Alex Jones or took
a crossing at this point and people
responded saying so is Crystal and Sagar
and and I when they why are we listening
to synced turd it's not it's not about
why are we it's about why does he have
millions of subscribers and get 30
million
why are you distracting me when I have
to leave you keep going down these dark
allies oh dude
I love the idea that we can bring
everyone together but some people are
just diametrically opposed to what we
believe yes after a while you watch that
guy talk and you're like all right let
me get a question these are silly people
let me get a question hold on there's so
many [ __ ] silly people you know like
you don't have to take into
consideration their statements about
every [ __ ] thing that happens with
every person you realize they're silly
you know they're silly that's why you
brought them up ignore no no I didn't
bring him because he's silly I brought
him up because he gets tens of millions
of views yes he he does he does he's not
if you look at all the views but how
many of how many individual unique
people are there it's not tens of
billions no no I'm not talking about
unique I'm just saying but it's the same
[ __ ] people it's like if tens of
millions of people they put out a lot of
content they have a hundred thousand
okay that's one question can we ask one
question but it doesn't matter do you
agree with them or disagree with them
you don't if you don't agree with them
you don't have to keep bringing them up
over and over and over again just
[ __ ] ignore them they're always
irrelevant as you as we make them yeah
that's just one question disagree
because I've been bigger than the media
for 20 something years you've been huge
forever that's why they cut your nose
but this is a real question I know you
don't want to sound Rockstar or Erica
yeah
it's a horrible person yeah [ __ ] you
it's fast
Nicholson I have a gorilla Chinatown
stay cut your [ __ ] nose Joe let me
ask this question okay Boomer we all Saw
Your Meme
what is it like to not just be probably
the most famous person other than like a
president right now in the world but to
have done it independently on your own
that's a major sea change I celebrate
that I'm blessed to know you're a great
guy what is it like to be at the
epicenter of the Zeitgeist that if I
thought about that I'd be [ __ ] well
it's a real question tell me I don't
know
black helicopters okay but you have but
it seems like as you've gotten it seems
like as you've gotten right in the
middle of the site guys you've gotten
more political involved not because you
wanted to but you feel like you needed
to because this it's not that I got in
the middle of the Zeitgeist this
pandemic yeah exposed the fragility of
our society that so many people are
willing to give up their freedom for
this like bizarre fake security that
doesn't exist like you're talking about
the most the most unsecure thing ever a
pandemic virus that's going through
people and then a solution a medical
solution that doesn't entirely work and
everybody's like forcing you to get
involved and take this and ignore all
risks because they did and they want you
to be on their side it's Madness and as
soon as you see that kind of Madness if
you don't say something then you fall
into tyranny and that's what the [ __ ] is
happening and whether or not people
realize what they're doing they're these
most of the people they're doing that
are cowards because if you stand up and
you say hey I don't think you should
vaccinate children people are oh
man oh that's what it is it's like
everybody's scared like you can't even
have to I can't pull in your cash but
here's the thing about it here's the
thing about you and here's the thing
about me when someone is unvaccinated
and they survives covet pretty [ __ ]
quick they go wait a minute I know that
was available and you go well how you
know when I made a video like three days
after I had covered I'm like I feel
pretty good like lies and then two days
later I put up this [ __ ] this test
it's like Tim said they were Maddie
survived yeah man I survived too but you
know it's because they took the chance
and they got vaccinated and they feel
like you should have done that too
because they realize there's a certain
amount of risk involved and they got
through it they're like you [ __ ] do
it it's like I jumped into the water
from the cliff you jump jump pitch I
jumped what about Aaron Rodgers who I
know you've helped out as well I mean
they're demonizing him calling him a
white supremacist on ESPN I'm I'm
flipping this channel I swear to God I'm
flipping through
it was a sports show and I'm flipping
through cable what's his name they call
them right wing
the big black guy and all I know is they
go he's a white nationalist oh that
guy's not a white nationalist that's but
this is like people say things to get a
lot of attention and they say things as
maybe they even mean it what that here's
the thing with Aaron Rodgers that guy in
any other time in history if a friend
calls you up and goes hey man you add
the flu what did you do I say oh I took
a z-pack I took a this I took of that
that was better and a couple I got a
vitamin infusion that's really big that
helped me a lot and they go okay I'm
gonna try that and they do it they get
better and they go thanks everybody's
happy like oh I would like to do what
Aaron Rodgers did if I get sick because
he was he was better pretty quick oh Joe
Rogan did that oh I should do what they
did because I'll get better pretty quick
I'm not saying don't get vaccinated I'm
saying if you do get sick this is what I
did and this is how I got better all the
decisions you make outside of that are
on your own I'm just telling you what I
did yeah
let us hear from you it doesn't have
anything to do with Pfizer it's just
human beings decide the influence that
Pfizer has is the minimal in comparison
the influence we have I agree I agree
that's what the real problem is is when
people do things and they make a choice
they want everybody else but you got
better in two days Tim got better in a
couple days it worked right I took yo yo
joe joe I was taking Ivermectin and I
know you I was right
like uh Ian was also really bad but the
reason the reason the reason I called is
because I was like I talked to a doctor
they said look it's a virus sleep at all
here's the thing it's monoclonal
antibodies or the big thing I took when
I said that I took Ivermectin I said I
took it in a laundry list of other
things that I took and I didn't say that
first I said monocled antibodies I said
z-pack I said Ivermectin I said all
these things but all they focused on was
ivermected the monoclonal antibodies are
super effective it's been proven and and
they're authorized for emergency yes it
is a it's a totally authorized and it's
the company's been around since 1988
they're not like giving liability
protection that's why I trust them but
Alex I also took Ivermectin when I was
got to go let me ask you one question
Joe okay I mean one question no one
knows you got better in two days you got
better than three I got better like a
day with this stuff Aaron Rodgers how
fast you get better somebody's never
even sick he's playing soon he played he
just won on Sunday he played so he never
even got sick with the pro no he was
sick before that he wasn't feeling good
he asked me what I did I told him I
connected him with some people and he at
his doctor got him all the proper
medications that he needed and
monoclonal antibodies and all the other
stuff and he got better fairly quickly
afterwards but also he's a [ __ ] super
athlete all right we're not talking
about like your 85 year old grandmother
yeah we're talking about a legit NFL
quarterback [ __ ] super athlete so to
comparing him to the average normal Joe
walking on the street is crazy he's
literally the elite of the elite in
terms of professional analog and I love
you I love you too [ __ ]
Joe's got a shove it so he's bouncing
out everybody
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time